in the last video i realized that i made
a a mistake near the end but it's not a
good one because i copied down the wrong
number and then that led to the rest of
the problem not having the right values
we figured out that the vertical
component of our velocity earlier in the
video is negative 26.03
meters per second but then i somehow
something happened in my brain and it
became negative
29.03 so this is not negative 29.03 this
is negative
26.03 meters per second so the total
velocity we should have 26.03
squared over here and then if we
evaluate that and i just did it on my
calculator 26.03 squared plus 5.61
actually i did it wrong again so it's
5.21 let me
let me redo it so 26
26.03
squared plus 5.21 squared under the
radical gives us 26.55
so this right over here should be 26.55
meters per second so that is
that is the magnitude that is the
magnitude of our final velocity
so that is the magnitude of our total
final velocity and the angle since this
is not 29.03 this is 26.03
we can say that the tangent of this
angle theta
tangent
of theta
is equal to just the the raw side this
is this value right over here so with is
equal to the this the length of this
vector right over here which is the
opposite side 26.03
over the length of this vector here
which is 5.21
or we could say
we could say if we take the inverse
tangent of both sides of this
that the angle is equal to the inverse
tangent or the arc tangent of
26.03 over 5.21
and that gives us
we have the inverse tangent
of 26.03
divided by 5.21
gives us
78 point roughly 78.7 degrees so the
angle here is 78.7 degrees
78.7 degrees and it's below the
horizontal so we can say we can say that
the vector the final velocity vector has
a magnitude of 26.55
meters per second added at a direction
of 78.7 degrees below the horizontal so
hope i didn't confuse you too much with
that mistake at the end of that video